the end of the road has only just begun
and fast ax leaves behind plenty of
questions for the next installment of
the franchise to answer here's what
happened in all the Furious action
warning spoilers for fast decks ahead
Dominic Toretto has faced a lot of
trouble in his life from International
Super criminals to members of his own
family but he's never faced anyone quite
like Jason momoa's Dante Reyes a
psychotic Mastermind with a major grudge
against the Toretto crew I'm Dante I'm
Shantae Dom and his friends killed Reyes
his father and stole the family's money
stash back in past five so Dante views
Dom as the source of all his suffering
he makes it his mission to make Dom's
suffering kind Dante sets the work
dismantling the entire Toretto family
and he more or less succeeds by the end
of the film leaving almost everyone in
some kind of dangerous limbo Tom himself
nearly escapes Dante's wrath atop a dam
in Portugal he finds himself in the
water below with no means of Escape as
Dante prepares to explode the whole Dam
and bring it down around Dominus son
Brian moments before Dom remarks that
Dante's one mistake was leaving him with
a car but now he doesn't even have that
it's hard to imagine how he finds his
way out of this one we'll have to wait
until the next film to find out John
Cena's Jacob Toretto was only recently
welcomed back into the family fold after
years of estrangement and resentment
after redeeming himself at the end of F9
Jacob devotes his time in considerable
talent to protecting Little Brian at all
costs taking him to a secret hideout and
then trying to help him escape with dom
so Uncle Jacob your dad sent me it's
clearer throughout that Jacob is also
still carrying a lot of guilt over his
previous actions he wants to be a good
uncle and a good brother to prove that
he's earned where he is now that desire
and the guilt behind it culminates late
in the film when Jacob realizes that
he's lost Brian to Dante and only has
one move left sacrificing himself so Dom
can get to his son despite Dom's
protests he goes down in a blaze of
glory taking out Dante's man and
clearing a path for his big brother to
keep fighting the film is moving really
fast at this point so there's little
time to mourn Jacob or to even confirm
that he's actually dead it seems like
he's probably gone but the Fallout of
his sacrifice is very much yet to come
Michelle Rodriguez's Letty Ortiz is sort
of the odd woman out of the Toretto crew
after the job in Rome goes very wrong it
makes her the last major Fighting Chance
a family has against Dante but he gets
picked up by the agency very early on
and she's taken to a black site where
she's forced to share a cell with
Charlize Theron Cipher who's already had
a run-in with Dante the two women don't
get along to say the least but Letty
realizes Cipher has a way out of the
black
when she gets word from brie Larson's
test that there's hope for the family
yet Letty decides to team up with Cipher
for an escape what she thinks will be a
quick way out though eventually leads to
the reveal that she's stuck in
Antarctica we leave Letty alongside her
former enemy with no real idea of what's
happened to the rest of her family
Dante's attack in Rome throws the family
into chaos and the Toretto crew spends
the rest of fast x divided but at least
tej Roman Ramsay and Han have each other
with few resources thanks to Dante's
hacking they Hop Around the World in
search of weapons they can use to head
out and help Dom they finally get a
plane load of support that will drop
them right into the fight in Portugal
what they didn't count on was a
last-minute betrayal aims who had been
the acting director of the agency and
was supposedly helping Dom reveals
himself as Dante's longtime Ally just in
time to hop up with a missile launcher
and shoot down the plane the last we see
of tej Roman Ramsay and Han they're
running for cover in the back of the
plane the plane crashes around the side
of a mountain and bursts into flames the
back of that plane was loaded with all
kinds of cool Tech they could use to
escape and upon's very existence has
taught us anything is that Toretto crew
members are pretty hard to kill so odds
are we'll see them all again it's not
clear how Ames managed to get to such a
significant post within the agency but
Mr Nobody isn't hiding and little nobody
is seriously injured in the Rome
incident so it means the man left in
charge test tries to fight him on it but
Ames is standing with the organization
and such that she can't use surface
Authority or stop his initial efforts to
take down the Toretto crew Ames later
endears himself to Dom then even later
doubles back and betrays him it turns
out that Ames has been working alongside
Dante for a full decade ever since the
heist in past five and his presence in
the agency was the leg up that Dante
needed to achieve his goals he may have
compromised the whole organization Dante
Reyes spends a lot of time talking about
suffering and that his father was killed
10 years earlier by the end of the movie
he seems to have achieved his goal of
squeezing out every ounce of suffering
from Dom that he possibly can every
member of the Toretto crew is either
apparently dead missing or in dire
mortal Peril I am the man who's going to
break your family
Peace by Peace So does that mean Dante
won we know the long answer to that
question is some version of no because
there's still at least one more movie to
go after this one but for the moment
there's definitely an era Victory here
if only because it's going to take
what's left of the Toretto crew time to
pick up the pieces the big question then
is Will Dante let all this winning go to
his head and make a big mistake Jason
Statham's Decker Chaw is only in fast X
briefly when Han decides to go to him
for help in securing resources to keep
up the fight against Dante but his quick
appearance is quite significant for one
it's the first time the pair have met
since Shaw seemingly killed Han years
ago it also reveals something even
bigger about Dante's fight
let's dig some Graves while in Shaw's
Hideout Ramsay discovers that the money
Dante stole from the crew's accounts has
been used to hire mercenaries from
around the world and send them after
everyone who's ever helped the Toretto
crew do anything that means dozens of
people are now targets including Shaw's
own mother Queenie who tried to help Dom
get out of Rome earlier in the film but
his mother on the crosshairs Shaw
Springs into action loads up his gear
and heads out in hopes of keeping
Queenie safe he's not part of the main
fight against Dante but he is heading
into something dramatic and probably
very bloody leaving us to wonder how
that fight goes we'll just have to see
what the next film will reveal about
Shaw's personal mission
several new faces emerged throughout
past Stacks including Tess Mr nobody's
daughter who believes in Dom no matter
what the rest of the agency says there's
also Daniela melshiorz Isabel a
Brazilian street racer who also happens
to have ties to Dom's past she's the
sister of Elena Dom's former lover and
little Brian's mother who died and Faded
the Furious Isabel's ties to the Toretto
family push her to help Dom fight Dante
and Dom's instinct to protect his family
pushes him to protect Isabel at all
costs by the end of Dom's adventures in
Rio Tess is seriously wounded and Isabel
is very nearly killed by Dante Dom makes
a decision to put the two women together
asking Isabel to drive tests to a
hospital leaving them both seemingly
safe from Dante's influence for now so
far they're relatively minor allies but
thanks to the mercenaries looking for
everyone aligned with Toretto they're
now on the crosshairs once again Mia
torreto played by Jordana Brewster has
been in and out of her family's battles
in recent years spending a lot of time
off and hiding with her husband Brian
and their children in fast acts she
hangs around to visit with her Abuelita
played by Rita Moreno in Los Angeles she
then watches Little Brian and while Dom
and Letty head to Rome when the agency
comes for them both Mia Works to fight
them off alongside Jacob who takes Brian
and tells Mia to head back to her own
family by the end of the film as far as
we know Mia is safe with her husband and
children back in hiding while the fight
goes on without her but we also know
that Dante has sent hired Killers after
the entire family and while Mia is good
at staying hidden she might not be able
to stay hidden forever once she hears
about what's happening with dom though
she might not want to stay hidden so
don't be surprised if she pops up again
in the next movie ready to fight
alongside her brother for years Mr
Nobody was a crucial Ally to the Toretto
family a leader with seemingly infinite
resources who saw enough potential
indominus crew to Shield them from the
Fallout of their missions his Protege
little nobody picked up that baton after
Mr nobody's injury and remained a major
supporter of the family while Mr Nobody
went into hiding now thanks to Dante's
machinations both nobodies are out of
commission Mr Nobody is gone little
nobody is injured and the agency is in
the hands of a turncoat so Dominus
family have lost some critical support
at the time when they need it most that
said neither nobody's is dead and they
got to lead positions in an
international spy agency because they're
smart strategic and know people it
wouldn't be surprising at all to see one
or both of them come roaring back in the
next film
Cipher begins fast X in a pretty low
Place Dante tracked her down blackmailed
all of her men and used her own
resources against her leaving her nearly
dead and in the hands of the agency but
while Cipher has been down before she's
never been down for long and she reveals
that she has an Escape Plan he's a
monster to battle with I gotta say at
the agency black site in Antarctica
Cypher reveals that she's not out of
options after all and summons a
submarine like the one she commanded and
Faded the Furious up out of the ice
that's impressive enough but the real
jaw dropping reveal is that she's
working with none other than gal gadot's
Gisele yashar who seemingly died in Fast
and Furious 6. giselle's presence after
years away raises a whole new round of
questions including how han might react
when he sees her again Cipher is clearly
still full of surprises and no surprises
might just force Dom to team up with her
Dante's war will clearly keep going into
the next film it's a big story so it
keeps going after the credits roll in
the film's mid-credits sequence Dante
targets another former Toretto Ally who
played a major role in the death of his
father Luke Hobbs played by Dwayne
Johnson who delivered the Fatal shot
Hernan Reyes in past five Hobbs
discovers that Dante has tracked him
down and here's a message that the devil
is coming for him naturally Hobbs
doesn't back down from a fight the
question now is how his fight with Dante
will connect to Doms and vice versa the
last time we saw them together within
the films they were allies who just
finished the mission that reunited the
family the Hobbes has been off on his
own for a while so it's hard to tell
just how close they'll get Dom and Mia's
grandmother is only present in fast acts
for a few minutes early on but she
leaves a lasting impression like Dom his
grandmother has endured tremendous loss
and she's learned through that loss to
value and protect the family that she
has left for Dom the fight is much
closer much more tangible even when all
he's doing is teaching little B to dry
so when his grandmother tells him that
with his family by his side he can do
anything that really means something Dom
clings to the idea that if he sticks
with the ones he loves and has Faith
they can survive what's coming for them
no matter how bad it gets we don't get
to see how he deals with the latest
round of losses right away since the
film ends on a cliffhanger but we do
know where Dom's focus is and what he
values because Abuelita us
[Music]